est ce que tu veux bien regarder la
caméra et faire clap clap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour monsieur delavier bonjour je te
remercie jaffray d'avoir accepté mon
invitation pour cet entretien
alors on va parler d'enseignement on va
parler du corps de l'esprit on va parler
de philosophie et on va surtout parler
de ton livre l'éveil des consciences que
tu es la générosité de m'envoyer que
j'ai lu que j'ai trouvé à la fois très
intéressant et très original c'est à
dire un peu inclassable dont dans lequel
finalement tout le monde va trouver des
des choses intéressantes et udu
parleront avant d'entrer dans le vif du
sujet je souhaite la bienvenue aux
personnes qui découvrent la chaîne grâce
à toi qui découvrent la chaîne du
précepteur à travers cette vidéo
donc si vous faites partie des nouveaux
spectateurs et bien je vous invite
évidemment à vous abonner à activer la
cloche pour être notifié des prochaines
mises en ligne c'est vrai pour toutes
les personnes abonnées activer la clause
sinon vous ne serez pas averti lors des
prochaines mises en ligne et pour finir
je vous informe également que si vous
aimez le contenu publié sur ma chaîne
que vous souhaitez m'encourager à
continuer bien vous pouvez me soutenir
via tipi via patriotes et via paypal
tous les liens sont dans la description
voilà c'est dit alors fred première
question même si beaucoup de gens te
connaissent déjà
est ce que tu pourrais te présenter et
nous dire pourquoi tu es ici aujourd'hui
alors je suis ici aujourd'hui parce que
une connaissance sur montpellier sabria
qui m'a dit tiens j'ai une chaîne que je
regarde qui est intéressante alors dit
ah bon je suis regardé puis j'étais vu
j'ai pas je ne sais pas comment je suis
rentré en contact réservoir de rentrer
en contact avec toi qui est un vrai
message sur facebook
non parce que tu as verleyen de mes
vidéos sur ton facebook oui oui d'autres
philosophies voilà pour la souffrance
voilà et quand j'ai lu ça je me suis dit
avec tiens je vais le contacter pour lui
proposer et généreusement voilà c'était
cette vidéo que j'avais regardé et que
j'avais relayés sur mon facebook parce
que vous faites
j'ai instruit les gens avec ce que
j'aime bien je le mets et puis alors mon
fan club entre guillemets m'envoie
souvent pas ce qu'ils aiment bien et
souvent comme on a vision générale du
monde qu un peu la même avec mon pigeon
qui me suivre ils m'envoient des des
choses qui m'intéressent alors des fois
tu vois moi je mets des trucs qui
m'intéresse ils suivent et e m'envoie ou
un message privé ou sur mon facebook des
trucs assez interactive ses intérêts et
moi moi j'ai une page facebook
extrêmement interactive et j ayew tube
qui est aussi interactif parce que pas
mal de gens y vont alors les quelques
acteurs comme d'habitude mais j'ai aussi
pas mal de mecs qui sans qu'ils
s'intéressent à ce que ben ce que
j'expliquais ce que j'enseigne et qui
m'envoient souvent des compléments via
des vidéos des sites qu'on peut mettre
en dessous des des communications sur
des des messages qu'on met sur les rails
youtube donc g1 g2 facebook est un
professionnel tout l'hiver et un youtube
et ça permet vraiment d'avoir cédé
réseaux sociaux qui permettent justement
deux de communiquer mais avec donc ils
suivent mais était enrichissante tant
que tu les enrichis alors moi c'est
énorme à moi j'aimerais en parler je
n'ai même plus quasiment à chercher sur
internet ça voilà et justes pour les
personnes qui te connaîtraient pas donc
tu as une chaîne youtube de frédéric
delavier ne trouvera facilement est là
est ce que tu peux nous résumer un peu
ce que tu fais sur cette chaîne et
comment si on est venu à créer sa chaîne
youtube
alors au début j'ai fait ma chaîne
youtube parce que moi je voulais
enseigner un peu sur la musculation
m'embêtait la musculation pour moi c'est
un un moyen détourné d'enseigner
la biomécanique l'évolution humaine la
paléontologie la traumatologie tout ça
c'est des choses qui le corps humain à
l'évolution du cocma c'était des choses
et de l'esprit humain après bien sûr qui
m'intéressait alors j'avais fait des
livres de musculation parce que pour moi
c'était une façon d'aborder l'évolution
humaine
moi c'est ma passion la paléontologie
l'évolution humaine via le corps et son
développement
je veux dire que tu as vente intéressant
musculation tu t'intéresses à bord et
moi de moi de tout le temps je me suis
intéressé j'allais chercher des fossiles
et quand j'étais jeune je regagne lisais
des livres paléontologie
j'étais passionné il y aller c'était
vraiment une passion pour moi c'est
intéressant parce que la plupart des
gens se connaissent par la musculation
et pas forcément sous cet angle avant le
corps humain à l'évolution du corps
humain c'était je rêvais d'une peu comme
dans fight club d'une humanité primitive
dans laquelle je pourrais retrouver ma
place
ces castes disparu l'homme à l'état pur
dans la nature qui impose sa force et
son intelligence est pas le petit gars
perdu dans une situation extrêmement
hiérarchisée où une bande de connards de
bourgeois dit puisqu'on parle plus
connus donc les autres si tu veux mais
je vais subissait puisque moi j'étais
plutôt d'en bas mais non justement voies
parallèles ça alors je rappelle pour nos
deux spectateurs que donc on va surtout
parler de son livre
l'éveil des consciences donc le lien
dans la description pour les personnes
qui souhaitent que le commander comment
il marche seul ce libre depuis sa sortie
j'ai cru comprendre que ça fonctionnait
plus tôt là on fait à peu près 1000 1000
milles ventes par mois ce qui est pas
énorme mais pour un livre de parentis en
page 6 et beaucoup 600 pages écrit petit
ça c'est l'équivalent d'un arrêt petit
moulin harry potter ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est vrai voilà donc c'est pas mal
surtout que mon le livre est à 27 euros
on peut pas faire moins puisque c'est
600 pages écrit petit abeilles luxure la
production des saints des beaux dessins
dedans il ya une maquette à payer
il a fait le prix voix c'est un très
beau livre moi je mens je recommande à
toutes les personnes qu'on va en parler
de toute façon mais ça très beau livre
est très original comme je le disais kim
est l'illustration est partie théorique
explicative enfin bref on va en parler
mais vraiment sans vrai sens on va dire
sans les gros médias classiques
c'est très bien puisque milles par
blizzard continue doit milles par par
mois bon on est content tu vois on est
content mais je suis surtout content pas
pour l'argent que ça m'apporte parce que
ça m'apporte rien mais pour surtout le
fait que la bonne parole parce qu'il
faut savoir que tout ça je le financent
avec mes livres sur la musculation le
fitness qui se vendent dans le monde
entier puisque cette année j'ai encore
vendu 200 mille livres dans le monde
entier ce qui me permet enfin de compte
de financer mon on va dire ce qui est ma
passion
donc c'est d'enseigner en fin de compte
l'évolution physique et spirituelle
voire l'homme et du monde en vérité
alors c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est
le lien qu'on va faire dans cet
entretien entre le corps les questions
physiques et et l'espé alors juste une
première question parce que tu parles
finalement beaucoup de gens te reproche
d'être de parler beaucoup de toi de dire
beaucoup jeu mais en fait on te connaît
assez mal on connaît pas très bien ta
vie on connaît pas très bien ton
parcours personnel et comme on est sur
une chaîne consacrée à la pédagogie moi
je voulais te poser la question quel qui
et quel genre d'élève
étais tu quand tu étais enfant qu'il
était en rapport à l'école ce que tu
étais plutôt un bon élève un cancre
qu'est-ce que infos que j'ai pas
tellement changé 1
comme disait johnny hallyday les hommes
ne changent pas ils vieillissent les
classiques et j'étais à peu près le même
en fin de combat - et veiller sur le
fonctionnement du monde mais avec tout
le temps les mêmes qualités c'est à dire
que j'étais le meilleur en sciences nat
dans les meilleurs en sport en lutte par
exemple grimper de corde en sprint en
triple saut bail et au but ce n'est pas
mon style de son auteur pas de pad
ouverture deux ans on ne peut pas
tellement il n'était pas besoin de
coordination
j'ai tout le temps été de même bon sport
bon sciences nat tout le temps très bon
en français mais surtout dans les
explications texte je suis pas quelqu'un
qui v qui va parler de ses sentiments tu
vois je suis quelqu'un qui plutôt essaye
d'analyser le monde parce que lui-même a
des problèmes pour expliquer ce qu'il
ressent mais tout le temps de meilleur
en explications texte ancien stade donc
tu vois que le mec qu'a pas changé j'ai
une espèce de structures de base qui est
fait est là dessus j'ai c'est la
développer en comblant mes faiblesses
dans des étrangers tous âges et des
mauvais en langues parce que moi mon
cerveau fonctionne avec un seul code
j'arrive pas à changer mes codes il faut
pas passer au code mathématiques
pailloux je comprends les systèmes
je comprends le fonctionnement des
longue mais j'arrive pas à les appliquer
j'arrive à analyser le fonctionnement
des langues mais pas les appliquer
pareil pour lui j'arrive à comprendre
les théorèmes mais je n'arrive pas à les
appliquer c'est roland jeu restant en
sonores et visuelles d'accord et on n'a
pas précisé tu veux aussi un grand
dessinateur
oui c'est à dire et et du réalisme voilà
beaucoup de dessins du décor la
morphologie et tu vas combiné en fait
c'est ces deux compétences ta
connaissance en morphologie et en dessin
pour illustrer justement de manière
pédagogique en fait les évolutions oui
évolution voila voila c'est à dire que
j'ai toujours bien dessinés mais j'ai
toujours eu un dessin très laborieux
comme léonard de vinci c'est à dire
c'est pas des saints comme michel-ange
qui est capable de peindre malevé très
facilement des des plafonds même si il
ya quand même très technique derrière
mais c'est quelqu'un qui était
extrêmement rapide et très bonne mémoire
visuelle qui était j'ai plutôt un dessin
analytique et construit par l'analyse et
par la correction permanente des erreurs
tu vois un peu comme léonard de vinci de
racine à peu près comme lui convient à
peu près le niveau en dessin j'ai à peu
près le niveau de léonard de vinci
ce qui n'est pas le même que le niveau 2
comme ils s'appellent qui de michel-ange
et d'ailleurs beaucoup plus vite
je dessine très bien mais mon dessin
surtout me permets en fin de ronde
exprimé à savoir comme un de massy qui
se disait donc je suis un ingénieur qui
dessine moi je suis un anatomiste comme
lui aussi
ingénieur je suis un ingénieur un
scientifique on va dire qu'ils dessinent
qui dessinent pour expliquer des choses
et mon dessin a surtout de la valeur par
le savoir que j'ai acquis moi j'ai un
énorme savoir date de mon anatomie
ce qui fait que je suis devenu l'a
activement la référence mondiale en
dessin d'un atome inutilisés dans tous
les bonnes écoles de dessin dans le
monde entier est utilisé par tous les
comment s'appelle le même et les boîtes
qui font les effets spéciaux du corps
humain bien sûr dont qu'ils utilisent
pas ce que je fais des visions 3d
projeté dans l'espace 2 du code du corps
humain écorchée par l'esprit bien sûr et
ça leur permet de travailler plus
rapidement donc je suis utilisant toutes
les écoles par dix ce moment la
possibilité qu'ils ont pendant mes
dessins de travailler beaucoup plus vite
en reprenant justement des écorchés
comprennent ce titre comment ça
fonctionne ou sincère des fibres
musculaires et c'est ça l'intérêt du
dessin que c'est que ça permet de faire
passer énormément de la forme soit là
mais avec un seul support à la lah ou de
parler crise serait de très très longues
explications et des baux technique c'est
plus compliqué de transmettre des
connaissances en dessin vaut mieux qu'un
long texte comme disait leonardo da
vinci qui est ici on le voit analyser la
voilà donc c'est un avantage mais ceci
dit jeunes des signes je ne décide que
comme léonard de vinci puisqu'il ya des
mecs qui sont bien plus douée dans des
sacs que new york c'est du lait ce que
tu ne t'appelles rsa du dessin au
fonctionnel c'est à dire kiki ce qui va
s'attacher à démontrer une fonction
voilà j 20 est de type voilà qui va
essayer de reproduire la nature telle
qu'elle est voix et d'essayer de
reproduire la beauté de la nature par
l'analyse alors qu'à des mecs moi j'ai
vu un match comme je disais hier je
discutais j moi j'ai vu une fois
japonais un mur entier l'a reproduit des
scènes de village et une grande estampes
mes pinceaux de trois heures c'était
merveilleux atouts que je suis incapable
de faire le mec avait les personnages en
tête
les dragons en tête les meubles tout en
tête c'est ce que je suis un cap
de faire par contre moi j'ai un savoir
on va dire savoir scientifique énorme
qui me permet et que le dessin me
permets de fin de compte d'enseignés
beaucoup dé temps de transmettre
beaucoup plus facilement celle avantage
ma force en fin de compte c'est d'avoir
regroupé le fait de savoir dessiner
extrêmement bien mais il ya meilleur que
moi mais à mon niveau dans les
scientifiques je pense pas qu'il y en a
d'accord donc de dessiner extrêmement
bien et d'avoir une très bonne
compréhension du monde et ce en
fonctionnement
bon de toute façon les spectateurs
pourront se rendre compte puisque au
moment où tu parles on voit des
illustrations de ton livre avec avec
certains de tes réalisations restons des
réalisations icaunaise la couverture la
couverture c'est moitié disent mais
quand j'étais jeune quand je voulais
être peintre je rêvais d'être peintre
que l'on me voit dans les salons
bourgeois à ses pigistes quand je me
suis aperçu que tout ça était stupidité
et orgueil mal placé
c'est à dire elle même l'orgueil tout en
a placé les orgueils c'était ridicule
mais en fin de compte
peindre pour exposer une toile dans un
salon bourgeois ou une [ __ ]
bourgeoise tu regarderas et à l'audience
durera de la vie'' ça n'a aucun intérêt
l'intérêt c'est de graphisme la peinture
de l'art c'est d'éveiller les hommes
qu'ils soient bourgeois ou google et
puis de toute façon cette reconnaissance
finalement sans la dezir et a quand même
fini par l'obtenir à travers des livres
un dalon voir des livres à côté de toi
la méthode de la vie de musculation
voilà c'est à dire que j'avais qu'à la
vente de te connaître en fait sur
youtube parce que c'est un bouquin qui
date qui reçoit lorient ce n'est donc
pour les jeunes qui voudraient se mettre
à la musculation là c'est un livre qu'on
peut aussi recommandé alors on va
revenir un peu sur ce que tu sais ce que
tu viens de dire mais pas tout de suite
parce qu'avant j'aimerais poser une
petite question
donc comme je dis on est sur une chaîne
de pédagogie alors si demain on te
confier les clés du ministère de
l'éducation nationale
quelles seraient tes trois premières
mesures des deux premières mesures
selon toi qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
si on était à la tête de l'éducation
nationale oh là là il faudrait déjà je
pense qu'il faudrait stopper l'éducation
nationale vers 13 14 ans d'ailleurs
bloqué on enlève tout le reste on en a
rien
[ __ ] et on veut voir les 15 ans et on
met une éducation on mais on on focalise
toute tout l'enseignement en fin de
compte sur les quinze premières années
de la vie des hommes pour leur apprendre
le fonctionnement du monde pour leur
apprendre s'ils veulent les maths pour
leur apprendre les sciences nat
l'évolution la paléontologie le
secourisme c'est très intéressant de
savoir comment fonctionne un corps et
comment sauver la vie d'un homme ce qui
est mise récemment je crois qu'ils l'ont
fait il commence à l'intégrer dans les
formations mais c'est très tardive parce
qu'on aurait pu éviter la mort ne pas
une personne mais de deux mètres des
langues l'anglais on peut dire oui mais
l'anglais mme c'est une langue mondiale
on commence à avoir un gros organismes
la terre où tout le monde est relié donc
il faut bien trouver une langue une
langue commune où c'est l'anglais on n'y
peut rien ça répète le français c'est
envie de continuer le français bien sûr
mais mettre des langues très tôt pour
les petits enfants pour qu'ils puissent
s'épanouir et tenter leur chance dans le
monde entier est apportée par me le
savoir france et à l'étranger ou bien
des étrangers viennent apporter le
savoir français en france près tout le
monde parle en ce moment un remplacement
de population bien sûr mais on va dire
un échange tu viens tu apportes sûr tu
vois c'est pas mal surtout que la langue
permet de comprendre comment l'autre
pense et donc de pouvoir s'adapter de
pouvoir mieux collaborer aussi avec lui
quand on sait comment il pense puisque
là on en parlera aussi le langage permet
de structurer la pensée
on sait que par exemple les allemands
placent le verbe à la fin mai ce qui
oblige les gens écoutent et voilà ce qui
rend les gens polis son but d'écouter
des frais jusqu'à la forme mais
lorsqu'elle marrant en allemand voit sur
moi je vis un peu en allemagne
c'est la façon dont les gens
communiquent et des gens s'impose
socialement c'est marrant à voir parce
que ça fait partie de mon livre si c'est
la façon dont les gens établissent des
liens sociaux et des liens hiérarchiques
alors le français il va te couper la
parole parce qu'ils pensent on pense
plus rapidement que toi si les instruits
qui l'a compris la fin de ta phrase donc
on voit les discussions dans les cafés
dans les bars ou les makes coupe la
parole à papy tu veux pas parler
excuse moi je n'ai pas développé quand
est entre gens intelligents on va dire
bien ça veut pas dire niveau social des
gens intelligents
ça veut dire tu laisse parler l'autre et
ensuite tu t'exprimes pour voir si tu as
bien compris mais là en france comme il
n'ya pas de monter sociale possible
qu'ils s'impliquent caste bas les gens
vont au sein d'un groupe établir une
hiérarchie en se coupant la parole et
c'est celui qui aura écrasé l'autre en
les coupant la parole et on s'imposant
par des termes techniques faisant que
l'autre ne comprends pas ce que tu dis
ne peut pas y répondre
elle lui va s'imposer comme os et celui
qui est plus intelligent en allemagne ça
se passe pas du tout comme ça et c'est
un pays rares chic mais en général les
gens et s'écoute parler il y en a un qui
parle l'autre va parler
l'ofc va contre argumenter alors ce qui
est marrant c'est que les gens s'impose
en parlant de plus en plus fort qu'un
hacker bonne affaire arrive à la fin
mais chacun s'écoute
mais ouf et l'autre continue c'est
complètement différente et voit solution
c'est marrant alors c'est un peu pour ça
qu'on voit par exemple
adolf hitler saoudite une histoire qui
ont envoyé par les voix qui l'a sauvée
montée précis et c'est typique à
l'allemand de monter progressivement
pour s'imposer
ils vont en écoutant noté tac tu monte
d'un ton qui monte d'un ton jusqu'au
moment où tu t'imposes et tu montres que
tu es le chef en parlant très fort voilà
ça c'est l'allemand né tu vois de façon
de parler différentes c'est très
intéressant très intéressant des grandes
robes au logis anthropologique mais
c'est pas ces deux peuples le français
d'origine celtique un peu latine et le
germain sont vraiment vraiment différent
dans la façon dont ce établir la
hiérarchie s'est passé pas des deux
français imaginent l'allemand mais il a
du mal qu'on enfin dollars réellement le
comprendre oui c'est vrai ça va ya
toujours il a versé valable comme une
comme un écran une barrière l'arrière il
faut vivre dans le pays pour comprendre
comment ça pompe comme ça c'est comme
faut vivre avec les russes pour
comprendre comment fonctionnent les
russes jédir se font vivre avec les
hongrois pour comprendre comment sont
les hongrois et tu sais de quoi je suis
pas à la wii mais dire on ne comprend un
peuple qu'en vivant avec en bouffant
avec un paysan avec c'est là
c'est la seule façon en fin de compte de
vraiment le le saisir
alors qu'est-ce que tu réponds à ceux
qui disent que les sportifs ne sont pas
compétents ne sont pas légitimes pour
parler de sciences ou pour parler de
philosophie parce que c'est quelque
chose qu'on a souvent reproché sa non
mais ça c'est typiquement français parce
que dès qu'ils passent les frontières
les gens n'ont rien à [ __ ] de ça ça
c'est typiquement français ça faut le
savoir
ça vient du système de castes où tout
est très compartimenté en france tu es
tu es déjà ce que dit oued à la
naissance d un bourgeois un pauvre
j'étais bien j'étais dans un café hier
j'entendais les gammes et les jeunes qui
parlent est derrière moi
montpellier et qui dit oh moi je suis un
fils d'ouvrier ah oui ce qui n'a pas de
sens parce que ou bien moi je suis comme
vous avez d un vieux qui dit je suis
polytechnicien lire donné par ta
naissance
ça c'est typique des paiements des pays
bas 1 ap et de castes c'est comme les
gens qui me disent tu devrais me tu
ferais mieux de rester dans ton domaine
voilà c'est exactement le reste dans son
domaine moi mon domaine c'est le manga
c'est le monde que j'expérimente si j'ai
fait du sport c'est parce que j'aimais
bien ça mais avant de faire du sport
j'étais garçon qui destinait très bien
et j'étais passionné de paléontologie tu
vois par exemple plus que l'histoire
alaba de paléontologie une biologie donc
le sport est venue après j'ai toujours
aimé faire du sport parce que c'était un
moyen de s'affirmer dans des quartiers
où il y avait une
on va dire pas une majorité mais une
grosse minorité maghrébine certains cas
banlieue ou strasbourg lieu où il
fallait quand même montré un certain
physique une certaine virilité pour
éviter de se répéter la gueule et voit
du coup du coup j'aime bien parce que
quand tu es costaud personnes t'emmerde
peu sa limite quand même sérieusement à
la confrontation et le sport permet
d'accueillir aussi certain
une certaine assurance voyage est
certaine voilà une ysern confiance et
puis en même temps même par rapport aux
femmes
quand on n'a pas forcément la richesse
on peut qui est de s'imposer
physiquement bien qu'elle s'en foutent
un peu mais bon toi tu y crois donc y
croyant tu te sens mieux et se sentant
mieux la femme perçoit un homme viril et
fier de lui alors ça nous amène sur la
quitterai à conquérir le monde est prêt
à conquérir la femme
voilà ça nous amène à la question du
rapport entre le corps et l'esprit
puisque justement en france sa gelée
constaté par le biais de mes études on
aime bien séparées avec une frontière
très nette le domaine du corps le
domaine de l'esprit comme on aime bien
séparé la pratique et la théorie
en france on est très axé sur la théorie
et sur la pensée on va un petit peu
dénigrer le corps qu'est ce que toi tu
penses sur le rapport entre corps et
esprit parce que ce sont des choses
opposées contrat dans l'ain ne va pas
sans l'autre
tu peux pas penser sans ton corps ton
corps peut pas se mouvoir sans ton
esprit c'est des bases
c'est ridicule voilà c'est là l'un va
avec l'autre si ton corps est malade qui
va penser comme un malade qui voit si
ton corps va bien tu vas pensé comme un
mec en pleine forme et ta perception du
monde sera différente
la qu'avoir proust un procès très
intéressant mais c'est ça lui a donné
une grande force perception du monde
parce que ne pouvant pas vivre le monde
et il ne pouvait que l'analyse et dans
un corps dessous trotteuse tu vois là et
ça rejoint nietzsche pas si tu as lu est
ce qu'ils disent est en fait qu on à la
philosophie de notre corps et qu' un
accord en mauvaise santé va produire une
philosophie en mauvaise santé est encore
en pleine vitalité au contraire va
produire un esprit un grand esprit voilà
non parce que oui c'est ma porte
ça va faire deux visions différentes du
monde
oui mais pas forcément mauvaise parce
que quand tu regardes proust c'est un
souffreteux il ya huit ans il est
il ya des preuves de bronches il est le
pauvre gars peut pas sortir
ça lui a donné par cette faiblesse la
capacité d'analyser le monde puisqu'il
ne pouvent ne pouvant pas aller
s'imposer conquiert le monde par son
physique il ne pouvait que par en fin de
compte l'argent qu'il ya été de sa
famille et l'analyse qui pouvait faire
du monde parce qu'il ne restait plus que
ça puisqu'il était fatigué en permanence
mais il avait la capacité d'analysé donc
ils allaient dans les salons il allait
étudier et là ils produisaient une
analyse énorme analyse qu'il n'aura pas
pu produire s'il était passé uniquement
à l'action du mec en pleine forme qui va
conquérir en tant qu'homme pour prendre
entrepreneurs le monde
tu vois c'est tes défauts font tes
qualités tu vois d'assez tout ça c'est
un but mais on vient on a des visions
différentes tu vois mais c'est
intéressant d'abord après tu peux être
un gros con aussi toi oui c'est pas
c'est pas eu peur c'est pas une loi
universelle mais c'est vrai que alors
une question très simple à formuler mais
sûrement pas si simple pour y répondre
qu'est ce que la conscience je peux
parler d'histoire du monde dont la
conscience la confiance et la capacité
de dire je suis je suis j'étais et je
serai l'homme est le seul animal a été
doux et de conscience qu'il fallait
définir la conscience et être capable de
dire je suis tout simplement je suis
l'homme
je suis celui qui aime match de dieu
c'est symbolique et la conscience est un
phénomène qui est
obligatoirement dans ce monde physique
connaît qu'une illusion mais dans ce
monde qui oubliant générés par l'ong qui
ne peut en fin de compte que ceux
réalisés par les lois physiques de ce
monde c'est à dire que le monde explose
ci-joint recommencement permanent du
voix et cette explosion énergétique
génère en fin de compte l'énergie qui va
générer la matière la matière sacré j'ai
en face agrégé en se fait en étoile on
génère des réactions énergétique à
l'intérieur en planète
si les plats ya beaucoup d'eau aussi
dans les molécules dont l'énergie à
former des molécules des planètes
si elles sont assez éloignés d'un est
d'un astre lumineux soleil à s'éloigner
pas trop près mais pas trop loin
elles vont conserver leur atmosphère si
la chance il y aura assez d'eau il y
aura des continents c'est ce système va
générer la vie la vie qui est la
réplication en fin de compte de la
matière nous associons des mystères que
les on a pas encore compris exactement
comment ça fonctionne mais on sait que
ce sont des automatismes
enfin de deux des lois physiques qui
génère sa la matière donc là les
planètes si elles sont bien placés vont
générer la vie la vie d'abord dans les
océans ensuite la vie va coloniser la
terre alors des végétaux des arthropodes
les veillées dans tout dans cette quête
de lumière puisque l'énergie via un
gambien du ciel les photons cette quête
d'énergie les les plantes vont se battre
pour atteindre 7,7 pour prendre cette
lumière montant de plus en plus parce
qu'à une compétition pour l'énergie tout
le temps l'espace étant limitées par
endroits l'espace viable ça va générer
désarroi sésame vont générer en fin de
compte des fruits des fruits qui sont en
fin de compte en même temps il ya des
lavis vga mais la vie animale face à
mios tout ça va se développer et générer
des bas des soins qui vont prendre les
graines les arrivent les fruits les
fruits c'est pour optimiser en fin de
compte le déplacement des végétaux et
leur croissance et leur multiplication
dans l'espace et le temps donc
appartement où il rougit ce qui entoure
et de pulpe et attire des animes des
animaux qui commencent à dégénérer
une adaptation à la vision lumineux la
vision des couleurs rouge tu vois les
variations entre le vert donc tu as des
petit insectivore qui vont se redresser
dans les arts pour monter qui vont être
instrumentalisée par ces arbres qui vont
leur leur montrer cette bombe calorique
que font les fruits qui sont entourés
d'une pub extrêmement énergétique qui
vont c'est qu'ils deviennent sucre est
justement avant elle son acide pour pas
être bouffé par l'apple quand la graine
n'est pas n'est pas apte à germer quand
elle est apte à germer le fruit devient
rouge
les animaux la manche donc il se trouve
que il a mangé ils vont lâcher un peu
partout ce qui permet aux armes de se
répandre sur la terre c'est cette lutte
pour la pour la vie tu voyais que là que
les petits ne tombe pas les petits
zèbres ne les plantes ne tombe pas en
barils soit pas gênée par le par la
maman maman ou papa qui va empêcher leur
développement donc ça va générer des
insectivores qui vont se rencontrer des
animaux certains taxis à cedar a cette
fois ils vont devenir gros puis si vous
mangez ils vont être en bas dans la
forêt ça fait avec des primates qui vont
aller chercher des fruits enfin le fait
de chercher des fouilles génère un
cerveau basé sur la recherche lac est
donc un cerveau qui va s'interroger sur
ou trouver des fruits déjà c'est les
arbres qui rendent les primates
intelligent va puisque
avec leurs fruits l'autre lui bouffer
des feuilles bas il va aller chercher
des livres c'est d'aller chercher des
fruits tu vois donc c'est un fait au
lieu de rester sur un arbre fait des
feuilles aller chercher des fruits s'il
ya plus d'énergie va être plus gros plus
balèze et en même temps il va ya la
quête du fruit comme la terre les comme
la planète oscille un peu non
l'engouement il dit a souvent au
rétrécissement de forêt de l'espace de
forêt agrandissement et des zones
herbeuses des zones forestières et des
primates se retrouvent bipèdes qui
étaient habitués à marcher debout il
s'était redressé dont on est lourd on
allait on a réfléchi sur des doigts qui
sont beaucoup plus courts puisqu'il faut
pas tomber des armes la première cause
de mortalité pour un primate c'est la
chute 1 c'est parce qu'il ya des
prédateurs sont en bas il n'y a pas
beaucoup dans les armes par les aigles
ils viennent doucher ou du ciel ou de
terre en intermédiaires on est sauvé il
ya des fous donc ils se retrouvent avec
marchant sur les phalanges admis
redresser donc plus facile d'être
redressée donc ils peuvent être dits ped
en forêts savanes énorme avantage mais
quand la forêt rétréci mais ils se
retrouvent bipèdes en savane en savane
l'avantagé c'est que tu vois loin et
puis tu peux aller chercher de la
nourriture en marchant dans les hautes
herbes
il ya quelques heures mais pas assez
pour manger donc été obligé de passer un
peu plus haut niveau tu vois un peu plus
tu passes de végétariens total presque
totale avec une alimentation avec un peu
plus de produits animaux pour les
carnets ils vont la quête alors comme
ils sont pas adaptés point des chasseurs
mais ils vont souvent les mains libérer
la locomotion et des bâtons à la
recherche de viande et de nourriture qui
vont chaparder à des prédateurs de
taille moyenne en général c'est un
avantage économique et le fait d'être en
savane avec les bras libérer de la
locomotion ça te permet enfin de compte
de pouvoir en groupe indiquer où tu vas
où
ou tu viens donc globalement ils sont
droitiers nous on aidera peut être
gaucher ou droitier pourquoi en fin de
compte quand est droitier ben tu prévois
déjà ce que va faire l'autre tu peut
serrer la main passe un objet plus
facilement quand tout un groupe et
génétiquement droitier sa facilité
échanges dans un groupe
sac le siège de la parole on libère de
broca droite gauche ici parce que c'est
inversement c'est le gauche qui
continuera donc là ce qu'on communique
avec la main droite
on communique ou non va où l'on vient on
met un son sur ce geste mais je leur
fais tout le temps parce que c'est la
base un personne l'avait expliqué donc
je vais à aa
je viens beaucoup dans les gestes et tu
trouves tu retrouves à des notions de
temps dans son langage puisque quand tu
vas vers l'avant c'est le futur quand tu
montes derrière c'est le passé donc tu
te retrouves avec une capacité de passes
parler du passé et parler du futur au
début qu'il façon très simple puisque
c'est juste un son qui indique le
passage dans la communication un futur
où le passage dans la communication
passé et ça ça te permet d'avoir des
notions de temps dans le langage qui te
permet de remémorer des actions passées
donc 2 en fin de compte épaissir des
connexions neuronales permettant
justement à des souvenirs importants de
ce grave et encore plus dans ta mémoire
et d'agir beaucoup plus vite par réflexe
espèce de réflexe conditionné que tu te
crées toi même dans la parole et ensuite
parler du futur c'est d'organiser à
plusieurs de prémédité des actions
futures de donnant une supériorité
énorme sur le reste en fin de compte des
animaux puisque eux sont bloqués dans le
présent dans leur communication ne
peuvent dire je t'aime je t'aime pas
j'ai faim j'ai pas faim tu es mon pote
est pas mon pote je suis en colère je
suis pas en colère mais ils peuvent pas
dire on va faire ça bien on va aller à
toi tu vas là bas moi je vais là-bas tu
vois ça c'est l'homme et le fait de
pouvoir parler du passé et du futur ça
permet de te concevoir spirituellement
sans le corps d corpore dans un futur
hypothétique ou dans un passé mémoriel
donc de commencer à pouvoir concevoir
l'esprit mais aussi de commencer à
pouvoir concevoir une façon terrifiante
la finitude de la mort puisque le fait
de pouvoir parler du futur
tu ressens la mort et la peur là tu peut
la concevoir par l'esprit en parler
puisque des cas de projeter dans la
finitude et de néons et la langue oise
terrible de l'homme le langage qui le
confronte en fin de compte à la mort la
finitude et là c'est le vertige du néant
hélas la pirouette intellectuelle en fin
de compte de nos ancêtres très primitif
c'est de se dire mais si je suis capable
de me projeter spirituellement futur et
le passé je suis capable de concevoir
l'esprit des corpore du corps donc
l'esprit qui perdure malgré la
corruption du corps due à la mort et là
commence à apparaître les premières
religions primitives avec l'esprit des
ancêtres l'esprit la nature qui est
directement liée à la bipédie notion de
temps et en fin de compte à cette
capacité justement de se concevoir des
corpore par des notions de temps acquise
par cette vie paisible et l'année
l'homme spirituel donc confronté à la
mort j'invente l'esprit esprits des
morts l'esprit de la nature l'espèce des
animaux et après je commence à inventer
des dieux pour finir par inventé dieu
l'ancêtre initial qui perdure sans le
corps en esprit et c'est ainsi que le
monde a généré l'homme et que l'homme a
généré dieu doit c'est une base très
simple quand on se tait les clients
c'est la science tout simplement
mais c'est notre corps qui génère notre
esprit notre façon de penser
tu vois j'ai bien compris alors s'il ya
des animaux comme ça l'éléphant oui tu
parles de l'éléphant comme une exception
dans le règne animal qui est capable
d'anticiper optique afin de s'établir
dans le temps oui parce qu'il a la
trompe
ils indiquent où il va où il vient et
cette possibilité de parler du passé du
futur c'est pas du tout entier qu'on ce
sont des énormes pachydermes qui sont
oblige
et de gérer un énorme espace calories
qu'ils vont bousillé un endroit
le problème des éléphants qui sont
nombreux c'est détruisent tout donc ils
vont partir plus loin et revenir
plusieurs années après quand ce rap ou
c'est donc une sélection des individus
qui ont ces notions de temps est de
retour au passé
quand on parle d'une mémoire d'éléphant
c'est vrai l'éléphant quand un cornac
lui a fait une saloperie il revoit ce
cornac dix ans après mais il écrase
contre le mur parce qu'il a fait une
saloperie qui s'en souvient mais moi je
défends jeu ils ont une notion des morts
ben voila j'ai bien qu'ils sont là comme
toile et il voit des désole sont là et
c'est cette trompe qui leur permet
d'avoir des notions de temps qui leur
permet aussi d'avoir cette angoisse de
la mort de la finitude
alors ils n'ont - ils l'ont ils n'ont
pas moins exprimé et qu'un homme parce
qu'ils sont pas les mains ils n'ont pas
les médias des traces des comportements
qui permet de repérer sa voix la cdu
justement aux notions de temps 1 données
par des organes directionnelle tac tac
tac toi je monte je montre passé je
manque le futur je fais je monte le
passé je viens le temps est liée aux
déplacements les traits de 13 ans va se
montrer ce que tu dis ça permet sur la
synthèse nombre donc je faisais souvent
en philosophie on pose la question de
quel est le propre de l'homme
alors il y en a qui vont faire le propre
aux hommes c'est le langage dont ils
vont dire c'est l'arbre qui vont dire
c'est la mort les animaux du langage
c'est les notions de temps qu'une notion
de ton fils je suis celui qui l'a m
science étant lié aux notions de temps
de son temps alors je souhaite laisser
moïse moïse quiconque est confronté à
dieu et il lui dit mais lui soir dans on
sait que je dis tout le temps c'est avec
le langage d'un pasteur de l'époque
c'est l'énergie il sait pas ne pas dire
cette expression énergie qui cotent
mobiles maintenant il est confronté à ce
qu'est dieu c'est dieu c'est d'énergie
l'énergie générant le monde générant la
conscience tu vois où la conscience
générale énergie là ça va dans les deux
sens et là en face d'eux il y avait mes
quiétude et le buisson ardent et dit je
suis celui qui est c'est à dire celui
qui est capable de dire qu'il est
d'ailleurs la conscience et ça c'est la
grande profondeur de la bible c'est
indiqué je suis celui qui est il est en
face en fin de compte de l'homme et
jésus dit je suis le fils de l'homme le
fils de la conscience un homme c'est la
conscience c'est à dire que
le monde la conscience du monde ne peut
apparaître quand l'homme elle ne pas
paraître ailleurs c'est pas parce qu
elle va pas perdurer en l'homme elle
peut très bien être mis dans les
machines
elle peut très bien progressivement on
n'a pas encore mais l'homme faisant
partie justement d'un vaste extension
technique qui crée lui-même du relais
les machines sont des extensions en fin
de compte de l'homme les ordinateurs son
extension analytique qui permettent à
l'homme d'analyser le monde téléphones
et les ordinateurs sont des clés usb
sont des mémoires en fin de compte que
tu n'as plus à mettre dans des petits
neurones parce que cela prend trop de
place donc tu l'aimais et en plus c'est
économique puisque ça va marcher
uniquement quand il va allumer
l'ordinateur que s'il fallait conserver
tout ça et en maître comme ça ça
consomme rétro tout est question
énergétique donc on a trouvé des moyens
pour augmenter notre puissance des
analyses sur le monde
notre puissance d'observation du monde
déjà par nos outils d'observation les
autres n'auront aucune est non oui tous
les appareils tous les appareils euse s
voilà c'est mesurer ce qui est invisible
plus nos capacités à stocker nez et moir
et à les analyser maintenant donc en
tout ce sont des extensions de l'homme
qu'on nous parle de l'homme augmenté mon
âme à la fraude un homme s'est fait pour
mourir mais l'information elle reste est
perdu on se transmet il nous la
conservons parce que ça permettra aux
hommes de mieux vivre et de mieux se
reproduire tout simplement l'information
lui fait pour transmettre pour aider en
fin de compte la vie a perduré et la
conscience à continuer à s'épanouir dans
les hommes on va dire dans un premier
temps là les hommes permettait en fin de
compte de vivre la relation à l'autre
vous à lui-même moi dieu a rejeté site
étudiant par 151 avoir conscience de soi
c'est être capable de le dire tu écris
certains animaux se reconnaissent dans
le reflet du miroir
mais être capable de se reconnaître et
être capable de dire je suis ce n'est
pas pareil
l'un a conscience d'être et se pense
extérieurement l'autre le dit c'est le
verbe le propre de l'homme
aucun autre animal n'est capable de dire
j'étais je suis et je serai l'homme est
le seul à manier des notions de temps
tandis que les autres animaux restent
scotchés dans le présent et d'extrême
que des émotions dans leur langage ou
des désirs présent ce qui les empêche
pas de se sous
lire et de lait qu'on est de concevoir
des actions futures mais en aucun cas
ils n'expriment le temps là bas donc ça
résume tout ce que tu vas nous dire et
ça me faisait penser ce que tu disais il
ya ce philosophe le site souvent eagle
je vais schématiser parce que c'est ça
l'auteur assez complexe et je voudrais
surtout pas à déformer sa pensée mais
qui disait que le le stade final de
l'esprit c'était le monde devenu
conscient de lui-même c'est le monde qui
se sait alors ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on a beaucoup de bas à contre a
conceptualisé ou à se représenter dans
l'esprit est ce que tu vas me permet de
comprendre c'est à dire que oui on a
bien compris à travers ta généalogique
ya pas de coupure entre le corps et
l'esprit
ce sont les lois physiques qui
produisent la console n'est pas tout et
pas de coupure entre nous entre le corps
la conscience et le monde
voilà c'est ça la clé mais n'ont pas
compris ça st toi tu penses pour un
homme indépendant mais nan tu n'existes
pas sans le monde te voilà tu n'es rien
je veux dire tu es le monde
j'ai le tuer le monde mais le monde est
en toi et tu es le monde tu es le monde
tu es sa conscience tu es toi je sais
pas oui voilà je suis moi frédéric soit
là je suis frédéric delavier quand le
mec commence à dire je me suis fais moi
même je veux dire hormis le monde
rien ne se fait soit mais bien au milieu
symboliquement tu vois là par les partis
sont dépendantes les unes des autres il
n'ya que le to qui ne dépend de personne
qui ne dépend que de lui même si dieu ne
dépend de personne contre dieu n'a
besoin de rien oui le monde dans son
ensemble n'a pas besoin d'une aide du
nord on va dire du de quelque chose
d'extérieur pour exister
il existe par lui-même mais ceux qui le
composent ne peut vivre que par les
interactions entre ces par contre les
partis qui le composent se voit c'est
ouais c'est chaque parti a besoin des
autres
alors je précise pour ceux que ça
intéresse donc que ton livre traite donc
de différents sujets c'est à dire que
c'est alors aujourd'hui on dirait que
c'est un livre transdisciplinaire mais
je ne suis pas sûr que le mot
correspondent en fait à ta démarche
je pense que c'est plutôt un livre de
synthèse dans lequel tu montres en fait
les liens entre les informations qui
semblent appartenir à des domaines
différents
ce ne sont pas du tout différent
maintenant tout est lié tout est lié
alors et tout est tellement lié que tu
peux autant parler de la conscience et
de dieu que de donner la réponse à des
questions qu'on sait peut-être tous déjà
posé en tout cas
j'ai trouvé la réponse à la question que
je me posais depuis longtemps pourquoi
les hommes ont des mamelons k-way tu
donne l'explication qui est biologique
purement en fait pourquoi nous nous
embrassons à celle là était bonne parce
que les mecs n'avaient pas trouvé c'est
vrai et c'est vrai qu'on se pose souvent
la question est finalement à quoi ça
sert de sombres c'est quoi ça sert de
s'embrasser finalité derrière à quoi ça
sert d'aller chez la chatte de sa copine
mais j'ai savouré le justifier par la
notion de plaisir en soi
non mais oui merde parce que le plaisir
en effet que pour ma revenir sur des
choses fonctionnent elles qui permettent
au groupe de deux survivantes et boisset
quelle est la valeur de la peep et de
cunnilingus et daniela gus g bordeaux
c'est non non non non tu vois les chiens
il s'échoue tu sais tu tu vas au zoo le
singe et un moment il était là je voyais
le stage il plante son doigt dans le cul
de lui vous attaquez way qui dit mais ça
sert à quoi
il est le réseau il ya une raison il ya
une raison toujours une ruse est
toujours une raison c'est des échanges
bactérien voilà c'est ça et c'est des
échanges matériels puisque comme j'ai
toujours c'est quand un homme et une
femme se rend compte et ça c'est propre
quasiment à toutes les cultures
ils vont se toucher ils vont échanger
les bactéries mais il faut qu'ils
échangent le maximum de bactéries pour
se mettre en conformité sion au niveau
des anticorps les deux pour protéger le
petit des bactéries de la maman
automatiquement il sera protégé dans
l'eau mais des bactéries du pape a aussi
qui sera donc le papa et la maman
s'embrassent parce qu'après ils vont
faire l'amour donc ils s'embrassent et
échangent des bactéries des fois des
bactéries qui peuvent être un peu
pathogène si t'as pas les anticorps pour
préparer la maman a pour que le petit
soient préparés aux bactéries dubai ne
soient pas malades
tout simplement donc ce sont des
échanges bacteria pour mettre en
conformation les bactéries de papa et
maman et c'est pour ça que dans les
groupes humains mais plus tu es proche
plus à des contacts et à des contacts
parce que ces contacts ont non seulement
marque pour la maman de stimule le bébé
ou montre génère du plaisir mais aussi
permettre d'échanger tout une flore
bactérienne qui met en conformation
d'abord le papa la maman et ensuite le
groupe proche et l'ensemble de la
communauté
en créant des anticorps permettant fait
comité d'être homogénéiser et ne pas
générer des bas des maladies qui
pourraient amoindrir sa résistance face
au monde tu vois je sais pas si tu
connais le philosophe schopenhauer
j'avais fait une vidéo sur sur lui sur
moi ma chaîne personnelle
schopenhauer disait que en fait nos
comportements individuels sont
déterminées par la volonté de l'espèce
et la volonté d'espèce c'est quoi et
bien c'est de se perpétue dans le temps
dans des conditions optimales et dans
l'espace dans l'espace temps les
génisses et que le ce qu'on appelle
l'amour l'amour et le désir sexuel ne
sont que des astuces créé par la nature
créée par le monde pour nous pousser
vers l'être avec lui avec lequel on sera
le plus susceptible de perpétuer
l'espèce voilà donc c'est une vision
philosophique qui développe ce qui est
vrai voilà ayant fait que tu rejoins
c'est sûrement mais ça va dans les deux
sens c'est à dire que l'amour est fait
pour effet pour perpétuer la vie mais la
vie est fait pour générer l'amour c'est
à dire que si le monde est ce qu'il est
c'est là qu'on touche à la théologie
c'est bourré et mais c'est la religion
chrétienne
c'est le monde est fait pour vivre la
relation à l'autre et pour aimer c'est
la finalité du monde
mais cette finalité du monde génère la
vie aussi vers la finalité du monde
c'est la vie mais l'amour c'est à dire
la vie générant l'amour l'amour générant
la vie c'est la réflexivité réflexivité
cia pas il faut concevoir le monde comme
à tout dire comme je dis tout le temps
un dieu conscience seul hurlant seul
dans l'été dans on va dire adieu hurlant
seul dans sa lette nm de sa conscience
n'est pas viable
tu comprends il a intérêt à se tuer
symboliquement a explosé en tant
qu'individu moi je pour exploser une
infinité de particules pour tenter par
la vie par la matière qui s'agrège par
la suite qui génère la vie de se
retrouver dans la relation à l'autre qui
va générer la confiance et l'amour ils
voient que l'univers c
le morcellement de dieu qui cherchent à
se réunifier à lui à se réunifier à
lui-même pour vivre la relation à
lui-même ou un autre un truc très
basique c'est à dire que c'est basique
c'est la big bang parce que pour toi on
sent que c'est maîtrisé c'est maîtriser
les acquis oui pour des tas de gens qui
nous écoutent là ils doivent se dire
mais il a fait mais quoi il devait pas
s'attendre à des call aussi aussi vite
je pense nos auditeurs ah oui mais
certains après il fonde et ils font des
crises et merde
ce n'est que ça oui c'est ça ton très là
parce qu'en fait je te cache pas fred je
n'ai pas dit mais j'avais un petit peu
l'intention lors de cet entretien de
montrer que tu avais un niveau que
beaucoup de gens ne soupçonnait pas en
fait quand il te vois non mais c'est les
français parce que les américains n'ont
rien des mecs comment il s'est beaucoup
de français qui te regarde c'est
beaucoup de français qui te qui te
suivent
et puis tes détracteurs ou s'ils sont
français alors forcément plus tu as de
l'audience est plus apte détracteurs
c'est mathématique mais je voulais aussi
prouver que ma derrière des petites
vidéos
voilà on va récupérer des petites
phrases pour en faire des mêmes ou du
genre de chose il y avait quand même une
vraie profondeur philosophique que les
gens soupçonnent pas et c'est
intéressant c'est que depuis tout à
l'heure je fais exprès te poser des
questions sur des philosophes et tu me
dis tu les appelles tu ne connais pas ce
qui est bien la preuve qu'on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir lu des philosophes nos
rangs une vision philosophique annoncé
une analyse du monde qu'est ce que la
philosophie
la philosophie c'est l'analyse du monde
dans le chasseur c'est la base
c'est-à-dire pour survivre j'analyse le
monde
qui suis-je on va c'est moi ça va être
monette qui m'appelle ne veut pas
s'arrêter là c'est bien on vous avez
oublié de couper semoun est une vieille
maman déjà grassement j'habite seul avec
maman dans un appartement
ouais c'est la belle patte d'oie cela
non j'avais la sortir parce que c'est
vrai que je suis en france à paris
sportifs et pour pour continuer sur sur
cette question là tu écris pas 169
j'écris quelque chose de très simple
dans le temps qui est très très puissant
la beauté c'est la fonctionnalité est en
fait ça c'est assez incroyable à ce que
dit comme ça de manière aussi courte
aussi elliptique ça paraît presque
évident tellement c'est simple mais en
fait c'est seulement en lisant cette
phrase que je me suis rendu compte à
quel point c'était vrai c'est à dire que
déjà le fait que ce soit écrit de
manière très synthétique finalement ça
permet de beaucoup mieux saisir l'idée
et c'est vrai que ce qui est beau et
fonctionnel ce qui est fonctionnel et
hbos alors est ce que tu pourrais
développer cette idée du rapport entre
beauté et fonctionnalité
ouais je lai j'allais me oui ce qu'on
trouve beau en général c'est ce qui
t'apporte de la plus un plus caloriques
voile alors plus reproductive seniors
avec canons esthétiques les mains la
beauté qu'est-ce qu'il fait qu'on va
trouver quelqu'un à l'arrière alors
d'après il ya le côté culturel de la
beauté dire quelqu'un beau pour un jeune
homme ou une jeune femme
c'est un être en pleine santé avec
l'harmonie on va dire qui veut dire
qu'on a une constitution faite pour
pouvoir affronter la vie se reproduire
est allé chercher l'énergie ou donner la
vie quand on est une femme donc un homme
pareil on ne trouvera une femme belle
quand tu auras les hanches montrant
qu'elle peut faire passer un bébé quand
elle aura de la grèce placé au bon
endroit pour nourrir ce bébé est une
femme qui a un gros ventre et de la
graisse viscérale montre qu'un un
problème est ce qu'on va dire
d'estrogènes on a passé tu vois mais il
ya des poils au menton ça veut dire
qu'elle a un peu trop de testo dax n'est
pas fertile à fond tu vois donc tu vas
pas la trouver très belle c'est donc là
il ya la beauté de la jeunesse
mais bien sûr il y a d'autres beautés
qui vont transcender la laideur d'un
corps en décrépitude non une vieille
femme qui plein de sagesse une mamie va
être belle elle va pas être belle par
son corps qui est un corps qui est en
train de se dégrader qui marche de plus
en plus vite on va dire vers le tombeau
mais elle va être belle par son utilité
qu'elle a en fin de compte et les traits
qui vont prendre en fin de compte
l'aspect d'une bonne vieille femme tu
vois une bonne mère
souriante avec et un comportement le
beauté de l'âme qui permet à ces deux
vieilles femmes d'être utile au groupe
en aidant les plus jeunes et en
transmettant de l'information
tu vois et en même temps en groupant en
unissant les hommes autour de ces femmes
pour l'aider qui elle même pas unir par
le fait qu il
et un peu fragile mais qui m'emmène leur
transmettre de l'information donc la
beauté peut transcender la dir la
dégénérescence de la décrépitude d'un
corps oui tu vois évidemment la beauté
peux tu deviens à l'est par rapport
si tu veux à la beauté lié à la
reproduction et lie à la quête
énergétique mais tu peux être beau par
l'information et par la générosité que
tu as redonner ton énergie ton savoir
aux autres là tu deviens beau d'ivoire
et là ça tombe bien c'est la transition
est toute trouvée parce qu'on va parler
un peu d'intelligence alors en passant
160 pas bon oui passes en 69 c'est ça
toujours tu développes une idée là aussi
philosophiquement très intéressante
tu dis l'intuition c'est l'intelligence
analogique et je sais pas si tu le sais
mais ça aussi c'est très platonicien
c'est l'idée que le stade supérieur de
l'intelligence c'est l'intuition c'est à
dire que c'est l'intelligence globale
qui fait que quand on a compris le tout
on peut comprendre chacune des parties
en concentrant sur nos automatismes
voilà alors je vais l'encontre cité si
tu permets comme ça que tu pourras
développe étudie par 170 le cerveau
analogique comparé découvre des friches
de nouveaux domaines de la pensée de la
compréhension du monde
le cerveau logique donc qui est un autre
type de cerveau affine et codifie ce
qu'a découvert sur le monde le cerveau
analogique pour permettre à l'humanité
dans son ensemble d'utiliser ce qu'a
découvert le serveur de logique et bien
que nous ayons tous en nous ces deux
types de fonctionnement cérébraux nous
sommes individuellement majoritairement
soit l'un soit l'autre l'humanité fait
de ces deux types d'intelligence les
cerveaux analogique et les cerveaux
logique qui se complètent pour permettre
aux hommes de conquérir le monde par la
puissance de l'esprit donc je trouve que
c'est très bien résumé alors pour les
personnes qui voudraient en savoir plus
est ce que tu peux nous expliquer ce que
c'est que le cerveau analogique ce que
c'est que le cerveau logique et
commencera une pose une colle la même
loi après tu peux par exemple le parions
qu'on parle du puy souvent bon alors
quel est le problème avec plus cuit
alors le cuisse et ça revient souvent
mais le cuit c'est une façon de
quantifier l'intelligence mais c'est une
façon de quantifier l'intelligence dans
un domaine bien précis dans sa ligne
pour les européens du nord
le calcul analyse et mais c'est à dire
c'est pas pour ça que l'individu va être
fonctionnel
tu vois moi j'ai des tas de mecs qui
disent j'ai accueilli lever les gens
sont méchants avec moi mais je vais
élever le mec dans la vie moyenne d'un
verre qui était venu me voir et me dit
qu'il est élevée les gens sont méchants
avec moi j'ai 145 depuis je viens
surdoué mais c'est pas grave utilise
sont enfuis pour vivre gagner de
l'argent pour aller voir les femmes et
baisers ouais c'est ça hein intelligence
est utilisée ce que dieu a donné pour le
faire fructifier et permettre à la vie
de continuer donc toi aller chercher
l'énergie à être heureux d'être dans ce
monde il puis à transmettre la vie pour
que la conscience du monde où dieu
puisse continuer à perdurer dans ce que
tu auras généré l'institut a un qi pour
te plaindre de supériorité que tu es un
enfant zèbres c'est la mode je suis un
zèbre n'en faisait les zèbres les uns
voulaient girard musiciens plus on en a
rien à [ __ ] à vrai dire je suis bien
content pour frimer pour nier mon fils
est pas c'est vrai que c'est mieux mais
ce que je dis à mon fils
il écoute on a rien à foot et puis
l'important dans la vie c'est de s'en
sortir
un d'être heureux et puis c'est pas
supérieurs ou inférieurs
t'as pas de plaindre parce qu'il avait
quelques petits problèmes à l'école
ils s'emmerdent on peut en cours et en
plus ça fait chier je comprends l'école
c'est chiant de toute façon je ne peux
pas les dire crise j'arrive pas à
montirat mon fils tu vois mais je lui
dis mais dit toi qu'il n'ya pas se
plaint d'avoir accueilli à élever comme
ces connards dis toi que c'est pire pour
ceux qui ont qu'ils sont cons qu'ils
savent c'est pire parce que le ca eux
savent que leurs possibilités de s'en
sortir dans la vie sont beaucoup plus
limitées
ils sont déjà moins concernant ce qui
sauve dit oui à la mairie en a qui
savent y en a beaucoup qui le somme
c'est très dur de savoir que tu es un
peu limité mais en même temps si tu le
sais ça peut être ça peut te permettre
justement de pâtes en bout près dans des
voies où tu seras pas forcément
performants
tu vois donc
ça montre bien et je te rejoins suivent
à ce beaucoup de gens contestent cette
idée mais qu'il existe non pas eu
l'intelligence signer des intelligences
voilà moi j'ai fait une vidéo dont le
titre était être trop intelligent de vos
bêtes
c'est à dire que quand ont surinvesti
une forme d'intelligence comme
l'intelligence logique on en vient à se
créer des problèmes de toutes pièces qui
n'existe pas et donc à se rendre
inadapté au monde
or l'intelligence c'est l'adaptation
l'adaptation à la cité l'adaptation donc
le sait pas c'est pas une preuve
d'intelligence que d'être inadapté
après il s'agit pas de l'attaqué ou de
critiquer les gens qui ont ces
particularités d'intelligence mais en
tout cas
l'intelligence ne se résume pas
intelligent ce logique mathématique
tu peux avoir 140 décrit m imparfaite
abouti qui sait pas qui c'est passé à la
nature de vis ou qu'il séparément comme
on dit ressentir l'émotion de l'autre en
face et donc s'y adapter être capable de
créer du réseau du réseau social etc
ah oui a été fait inadaptée elle n'est
pas parce que tu sais calcul que tu
arrives à te t'adapter dans un réseau
social prendre ta place et devenir utile
pour le groupe dévoilé mais qu'il est
inadaptée mais j écoute utilise son
intelligence pour gagner de l'argent et
aller baiser les filles alors juste
avant sa mort
ça m'amène à ce petit essai mais c'est
un business il ya aussi le fait que le
cui est souvent un business pour assurer
les mamans donc ils veulent tout le
temps savoir que leur fille stagne à 180
euros et qui m'a dit que si toutes les
mamans font ça le mec il est plein aux
as tu devrais je pas l'embêter
moi je donne des cours particuliers à
des gamins qui parfois sont très fiers
de man on sait qu'ils ont des
difficultés à l'école parce qu'ils sont
précoces ou parce qu'ils ont accueilli
au dessus de la moyenne et donc il
opportun peu comme un étendard et de
fierté
ouais c'est là et après ils font plus
rien c'est ça ça justifie en fait le
fait qu'il n'y arrive pas donc ils ne
font plus rien parce que de toute façon
c'est un vote des autres ils sont trop
intelligents fois le nom c'est ta faute
tu as ta faute tu es responsable de rien
mais c'est pas une raison si tu veux tu
dois utiliser s'initie le bas tu fais le
fautif y est ou bien la home est un
crève quoi malheureusement si besoin
c'est la vérité tu crèves tu marches du
greffe c'est la vie est ce pareil c'est
pareil et puis le clip ne garantit pas
une réussite c'est un avantage
maintenant si tu parles d'un site il
sait pas l'exploiter c'était pas aussi
intelligent que tu le crois alors par
171 tu dis certains pensent vite nepeut
way
d'autres pensent lentement mais tout le
temps l'important étant de pensées
utiles
voilà c'est moi et moi je prends suis
assez lent moins dépensé de moins en
moins parce que je me suis créé des
automatismes de réflexion mais elle a
pas je suis très long mais j'ai compensé
en étant en pensant tout le temps
d'accord témoin ouais ouais je vois je
vois donc pas le 169 à 173 on a une
succession de petits aphorismes sur
l'intelligence donc là encore je vous
renvoie au livre l éveil des consciences
un jeu je le remets à l'écran pour pour
les personnes qui voudraient le lire et
se le procurer le lien est dans la
description
alors on arrive disons plus ou moins way
dans la dernière partie de cet entretien
on va dire pas 187 tu parle du rôle de
l'humour dans la parole publique donc
dans l'acte de transmission finalement
et il se trouve que bon là on se connaît
un petit peu maintenant
des fois je m'oublie j'oublie un peu ce
que ce que je dis hein comme dit tout le
temps oui mais ça s'étudie tout le temps
pour me pour m'instruire je me relis oui
et pour briller en société je me cite le
problème c'est que j'oublie ce que j'ai
dit il ya le problème c'est que je
laisse les j1 stocker parce que mon
cerveau fait la place way à d'autres
trucs donc c'est aux régulateurs de
liste du goût qui vont aux cités et du
coup il va pouvoir disent ah oui merde
mais là pour le coup je pense que ça va
parce que alors lorsque j'allais te dire
en fait c'est que là depuis qu'on se
connaît c'est à dire depuis quelques
heures à peine bon tu es quelqu'un qui a
un qui a de l'humour qui est assez drôle
et qui a bien rire est dans tes vidéos
cet humour tu ne mets pas forcément
avant à moins que tu fasse de manière un
petit peu indirect est subtile mais
qu'est ce que tu peux expliquer en quoi
l'humour peut être utile je n'ai pas
marqué dans le texte ça serait mieux que
tout le livre parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
choix j'ai des fois j'ai oublié un peu
tu vois les jeunes vont pouvoir réagir à
ta propre citation comme ça écoute tu
veux venir prendre la parole en public
pour imposer sa façon de penser est
toujours une chose dangereuse car on
risque la désapprobation générale était
par réaction l'exclusion du groupe avant
l'âge anciens bibelots plus simple pour
la majorité des gens de se taire
d'écouté
de suivre la volonté du groupe faire de
l'humour permet principalement de
prendre la parole sans risque car
l'humour est une protection pour faire
passer des choses importantes dans un
message en indiquant par l'humour c'est
à dire en y ajoutant de l'irréel et de
l'illogisme qu'on ne veut ni s'imposer
hiérarchiquement les contester
sérieusement l'ordre établi ça te
revient oui ça me revient oui mais oui
c'est une façon de se protéger mais
c'est aussi apprécié parce que ça permet
des tournures d'esprit qui monta
vivacité aussi il est important pour les
familles la du mois les femmes les
hommes qui ont du mouvement étant une
preuve d'intelligence la roue le coup
voilà les parce que ça permet de montrer
qu'on est capable de jouer avec des
tournures de phrases et de des zones
motogp mais voilà les femmes aiment
l'humour des accords théo restera qu'une
femme tu lis or une blague et il ya pas
de contact at elle rigole elle adore ça
peut-être pas comme ça la compagnie des
eaux est très drôle
c'est marrant je reviens un petit peu
sur pour terminer parce que je voulais
vraiment parle sur la beauté la
fonctionnalité tu parles de la poésie
justement ça ne fait pas ça les mecs ils
ont ça j'aime bien parce que la poésie
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui a ancré
dans l'homme la poésie le riz mais c'est
pas du tout quelque chose qui n'est pas
calculable
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui permet
de mémoriser des informations utiles
voilà alors je vais te lire là encore si
la poésie est belle c'est parce qu'elle
est plus facile à mémoriser que la prose
c'est de la parole travailler et
harmonisées pour la mémorisation et pour
ainsi transmettre des informations par
delà la vie et après la mort sans
support matériel
voilà ça c'était à la base c'est pour ça
que les ce qu'on appelle les cultures
traditionnelles en marque haïk qui n'ont
pas forcément beaucoup de technicité
d'évolutions techniques parce qu'ils ont
été isolés ne sont pas donc il n'y a pas
eu de transmission de beaucoup
d'informations entre les groupes en
général elles sont réelles sont dans la
poésie souvent dans la façon de parler
avec justement avec des harmonies
vocales à l'harmonie sonore des armées
de rythme ce qui permet de en fin de
compte d'aller plus facilement chercher
l'information a prise dans le cerveau ne
les cherchez plus vite et de la
retransmettre
en afrique on voit ça partout dans les
fables de la fontaine qu'on apprend à
l'école assez pour c'est pour permettre
justement de mémoriser des choses très
important de la morale est très très
très important avec justement c c'est
l'enseignement qui sont très faciles à
les retrouver dans la cervelle dans la
parce qu'en fin de compte seule dos a
dit explique t ces jeunes explique prend
tout le temps c'est une blague tus il
faut être pédagogique comme je te dis je
t'encule ursule c'est toujours plus
facile j'avais fait tout le temps parce
que c'est rigolo c'est plus facile à
mémoriser que je te sodomise ursule
pourquoi parce que je t'encule ursule
c'est la même longueur donc la même
vibration des en cumul le recul même
structure tend même longueur même
temporalité et sonorités sas et ursule
[ __ ] hull
donc ça sera stockée dans les mêmes en
partie dans les mêmes neurones est
beaucoup plus facile
aller chercher le début de la phrase et
la fin de la phrase le début de la
phrase quand tu es le début de la phrase
tu vas tout de suite cherché le début de
la phrase parce qu'elle est à moitié
stockés dans les mêmes neurones donc ça
va beaucoup d'informations ce transfert
beaucoup de mesure et dès que tu chopes
la 1ère partie la deuxième qui revient
voilà c'est le principe des dictons
voilà les ddd même des slogans à la
mêlée dicton populaire voilà qui vole un
oeuf vole un boeuf voilà ça la
signification quand j'étais enfant dès
fois ses tics ton ces proverbes je les
comprenais pas mais je les avais
renouvelables et du coup les a lésés en
retenue j'ai pu comprendre après ce qui
voulait dire effectivement c'était un
moyen de transmission de l'information
et de l'enregistrement de ce mois là ce
sont hélas est justement c'est juste ça
donc c'est pour ça que c'est beau et
c'est pour ça que je crois que dans le
coran une bonne partie qui en rythmant
au moins harmonie et une belle parole
c'est une parole qui a harmonisé qui est
un rythme qui arrive pourquoi parce que
ça se retient beaucoup plus facilement
tu vas chercher la seconde
le second texte dans un homme qui est
mémorisé à peu près au même dans les
mêmes neurones puisqu'il a à peu près la
même structure temporelle la même
longueur
donc c'est pour ça que un grand
enseignant est un enseignant qui
enseigne
au niveau verbale avec rythme et avec
rim
tu vois la supposée faut pas exagérer
non plus mal français c'est l'excès
puisque le français beaucoup de
synonymes qui permet de faire beaucoup
de verts tout ça mais à des langues ou
c'est un peu moins facile de le faire
tu vois donc il va jouer sur d'autres
trucs mais là le rythme et tout le temps
utilisé sur parler en rythmant le rythme
respiratoire teinte à ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta c'est mieux qu'un truc qui saccade
et tu vois tu vois ça dans toutes les
langues
c'est une façon de transmettre plus
facilement l'information donc la belle
langue parlée
c'est pas un truc qui n'est qu'on ne
peut pas définir
oui c'est défini en fonction du rythme
de l'intensité de la sonorité pour
facilement aller chercher l'information
et la restituer ce qui est le plus
important
tu vois notamment parce 207 alors au
tamis draps là dessus tu fais un petit
paragraphe sur le mauvais enseignants
puis après on passera sur le bonne
enseignants c'est beaucoup plus rapide
alors le seul mauvais enseignants tu
dises ce qui me fait de la peine c'est
que bien souvent l'enseignant cache son
incompétence et sa mauvaise
compréhension du sujet qui devrait
maîtriser par une avalanche de termes
techniques pour permettre savants et
hypnotisé son auditoire
au final les gens n'ont rien compris
mais ils retiennent juste des noms
compliqués ce qui leur donnera
l'impression qu'ils sont instruits et
les rassurera sur leur niveau
alors qu'est-ce que tu es ce que tu
pourrais le dire pour complétèrent ne
sait assez souvent l'éducation nationale
française voit des mecs qui sont là qui
savent qu'ils sont médiocres il pour ne
pas montrer en fin de compte aux élèves
qui sont médiocres bas ils vont vos
masques et cette médiocrité dans
l'enseignement ouvert sur cette non
passion qu'ils ont ou 7,9 véritable
connaissance avec des termes techniques
qui vont faire que ce qu'ils vont dire
va être papa être compris par les élèves
mais comme ces techniques ne lève
n'osera pas dire qu' il n'a pas compris
et n'osera pas contredire le prof
il était tellement intelligent que je
n'ai pas compris ce que les avions non
c'est un connard tu vois oui parce qu'il
accueille l'étape après s'il est
tellement intelligent qui comprend même
pas ce qu'il dit oui c'est ça c'est non
un prof intelligent ca prof qui est
capable d'exprimer simplement des choses
compliquées c'est très dur c'est tout un
art
et c'est de l'intelligence c'est pas
d'exprimer avec des termes compliqués
pour en fin de compte se persuader qu'on
est attrayant parce que malheureusement
ce n'est pas que les élèves qu'ils
essaient de persuader qu'ils sont
instruits c'est eux-mêmes alors qu'en
vérité c'est des bons connard j'ai vu
plein de profs qui les trous du cul fini
s'est il l'a surtout dans l'enseignement
national français temps on a moins aux
états unis parce que souvent c'est des
organismes privés qui demande la
performance parce que sa vie avec le
pognon des gens qui payent l'on va dire
le système éducatif et s'ils n'ont pas
de performance derrière ben y'a plus
personne qui viendra dans
l'établissement et ça c'est cool
donc ils sont obligés de prendre des
bons les enseignants et quand tu vois un
enseignant américain qui explique alors
on peut le voir quand on regarde des
traductions sur internet des enseignants
américains
c'est souvent limpide cantine quand il
parle de quelque chose et ça faisait
accessible même un des des scientifiques
des revues scientifiques américaines
sont souvent beaucoup plus accessible
que des revues françaises
et on en revient à cette culture de de
la pratique de l'action il faut que ça
soit compréhensible pragmatique parce
que le business des regards que ce soit
qu'on puisse le mettre en application
immédiatement et donc faut que ce soit
compris ou là en france où dort à
condensats à se plaire et se complaire
démo technique mon grand tu as castells
à dire que je parle avec un certain
langage scientifique qui fait que je
suis compris comme un scientifique
faconde ja soit ma situation où et
social mais c'est comme ces cellules
comme le pierre bourdieu qui explique la
domination des élites intellectuelles
dans des livres incompréhensiblement
masse voilà qui se rend même pas compte
en écrivant son livre qui dénonce
quelque chose sur le plan sociologique
dont il est lui-même finalement
l'incarnation et c'est à dire un mépris
de classe inconscient puisque finalement
quand on fait aucun effort pour
s'adapter
ça reste une forme de mépris jusqu'au
bout c'est en tout cas de l'indifférence
il placé et et on peut avoir des
discours pour dénoncer l'élitisme
finalement on être partie prenante oui
on l'avait qui a des terres moi c'est ce
que je vois quand je fais des bottes des
émissions des télés mais des émissions
internet puisque maintenant ça remplace
mois six mois la télé tu as des gens me
sens très bien avec un bon fond qui
continue à parler avec des termes
techniques parce qu'ils ont ce 3ème de
classe tu pour essayer de s'affirmer
message sans se dire mais ce mot
technique pour être remplacé par mon
beaucoup plus facilement compréhensibles
par la masse puisque le but est quand
même d'étudier des veillées le maximum
de personnes
évidemment quand je suis avec mon pote
gundy l'on va pouvoir parler de trucs
avec des termes plus scientifique
tu vois les bus cld et nerveux tout ça
mais j'ai pas le faire mais tout le
monde ça n'a aucun intérêt elles
intéressent et d'enseigner un maximum à
un maximum d'individus pour en faire des
hommes libres pour faire dézoner
réveiller avec un savoir qui leur a
permis de maîtriser le monde maîtriser
leur vie l'envi et le monde
tu vois c'est ça mais malheureusement en
france il ya ça est ce que tu te
considères comme un bug non c'est lyon
ah bah oui puisque je suis suivie à oui
puisque je vends bien comme j'ai tout le
temps à quoi reconnaît-on un bon
philosophe à ses ventes pour énerver les
mecs
oui mais on dit quand même pas mal de
bouquins tu voi houthis compte répondre
à la su que j'allais sans pub
oui sont donc ça plaît je fais quand
même cette année j'ai fait plus tu
penses plus de 200 milles en fin de
compte - non c'est plus deux cent mille
bouquin sans pub c'est à dire que mon
livre meslif plaisent parce que
l'enseignement est concret mais je pense
que tu as well as en face même si je
comprends ton argument n'étant pas dans
le même système c'est à dire
moi le seul retour que j'ai par exemple
seront d'enseignement c'est vrai que le
retour de mes élèves ou des parents
d'élèves et je pense que tu as aussi
beaucoup de retours d'internautes ou de
gens car oui et à qui tu as dû apporter
des choses des éléments de réflexion
oui moi je moi je mon but c'est de les
sauver et sauver parce que moi j'ai
failli plusieurs fois en fin de compte
m'écrouler mourir parce que
l'enseignement qu'on m'avait donné tes
faux tu vois c'était un enseignant était
vicié une vision du monde qui étaient
fausses qui étaient là que pour en fin
de compte maintenir un système de castes
en place quitter m attends moi je sais
pas j'ai pas envie d'être un esclave
toute ma vie mon faisait croire tué
jeudi tout le temps la modestie et dans
les meilleures idées pas modeste moi
j'aime bien la sorte et la sorgue et il
a investi c'est la seule qualité des
gens qui n'en ont pas d'autre
oui oui alors ça c'est un proverbe
lloris que j'ai mis dedans et j'ai remis
dans mon bouquin
c'était ma copine elena qui sortait sa
ex prêter c'est parce que les russes et
les mains qui s'imposent du crm parme
voilà c'est un rude comme un comme un
rush puissiez l'autocritique russes tu
vois mais c'est vrai la france est un
pays de castes donc c'est un pays où
t'as pas intérêt d'avoir une classe
inférieure qui va monter puisque qui dit
qu'un individu ni classe inférieure
monde m'a dit qu'un individu d'une
classe supérieure une caste qui descend
donc comme c'est un pays caste t'as
intérêt d'éduquer le peuple a la
modestie c'est à dire que comme j'ai
tout le temps il était tellement modeste
qu'il est mort avec ses grandes qualités
sans que personne ne sache
tu vois non en vérité c'est si tu as des
qualités fait l'ebrié crier sur tous les
toits du mois je suis bon dieu bien sûr
si tu es persuadé que tu les a pas
citées affoué lumineux tu le dis pour
t'imposer et pour que ses qualités
tu es tu toi même à monter et aide ton
groupe qui est le garant de la survie
donc c'est ça la modestie c'est dire moi
je suis très fort moi je suis le
meilleur ou tel domaine
moi je suis bon moi je suis fort en
france on t'apprend dit non quand on est
bon c'est les autres qui vont s'en
apercevoir maintenant personne va t'en
apercevoir
c'est fait pour écraser la vie est faite
comme ça quand tu as une place tu fais
tout pour que les mecs qui sont en bas
ne monte pas parce qu'un mec qui monte
prends ta place et empêche en fin de
compte en tant qu'individu 2
de t'asseoir attendent sur ta place où
tu aimes ou tu peux chercher les merlus
n'a plus tout le monde tourne à
d'énergie puis on peut à la rigueur base
sur produire même si ce n'est pas tout
le temps le cas donc tu vois le mec qui
en dessous qui montent comme une
concurrence donc il va alors que si tu
vois dans un groupe une vision globale
un mec qui monte c'est un bon mec du
pouvoir qui va remplacer un mec qui est
moins bon mais pour le bien du groupe et
la solidité du groupe dans son ensemble
c'est plus efficace parce que ça pourra
ce groupe sera plus résistants pourra
lutter contre d'autres groupes humains
qui se battent pour défendre une
compétition énergétique et territoriales
donc c'est bien quand les frontières
sont fermées ottoman ça marche plus et
un tuba sol et de l'est mais caen battu
dit la modestie tu les as prend un nain
par la religion à s'acquitter de leur
tâche en fin de compte de serre à obéir
aux s'usera et leur dire si tu obéis
bien par l'éducation l'église durera au
paradis tu ira au paradis parce que tu
auras obéit aux nobles qui lui est nommé
en fin de compte et la volonté divine
ah c'est vrai d'accord et tout mais à la
société marque chez dunlop jouent le jeu
et permet une répartition énergétique
quand même correct mais par rapport à
des sociétés on va dire une méritocratie
où il ya quand même comment ni dans nos
verres en une rotation des individus au
sein de ces groupes humains ceux là sont
plus énergiques même si c'est plus
instable en interne ses plus puissants
dans une prédation entre les groupes
dans une lutte entre les couples donc
c'est tout le temps un équilibre est ce
que tu te souviens de ce que tu as dit
sur le o m je suis définit le bon mètre
à travers une seule phrase ce que tu
t'en souviens vaguement suis écrit le
bon mètre et celui qui enseigne si bien
que ses élèves finissent par le débat ça
rit c'est la base
c'est la base des cinémas ce qu on a
complètement oublié enfin coloris est en
tout cas quand on définit ce qu'est un
bon mètre c'est un peu la finalité que
l'élève dépasse le maître
c'est là qu'on se rend compte qu on a
été un bon enseignant voilà c'est la bad
s'est toujours montée vers la vers le
mieux et toi tu n'es qu'un passage
d'humeur et finalement
on n'a pas besoin d'être modeste quand
on a cette ambition puisque c'est
l'ambition la plus moderne et du savoir
précisément de se laisser dépasser par
là celui qu'on n'est pas contents mais
merde m'a dépassé mais celles à l'eau
c'est la loi la loi du monde
oui tu vois c'est qu'on peut voir fier
le père le père jaloux que son fils le
dépasse devienne un homme plus
performant que lui après tout dépend de
ce que fait le fils ou le disciple de
ceux de cet enseignement si le détourne
à des fins personnelles ou nuisibles
c'est pas vendredi
ça c'est pas bon non c'est pas un bon
élève puisque c'est mon élève c'est
quelqu'un qui agit pour le groupe et lui
même mais pas que pour lui même si il
agi que pour lui-même à plus ou moins
long terme et détruira le groupe et le
groupe étant le garant de la survie
d'individus il m'a été dit sur lui même
ou sa descendance puisqu'il va rendre
instable groupe donc tout ça est une
question d'essayer les questions
soulevées dans star wars qui est ta
vador qui est l'ancien disciple
justement qui qui passe du côté obscur
et qui du coup exploit tout ce qu'il a
appris pour le mettre au service du mal
et donc de la destruction du groupe
il devient finalement celui qui va
catalyser le groupe autour de lui donc
pour finir sur sur cet entretien fred je
te propose de revenir simplement sur une
phrase que tu écris au tout début de ton
libre il servira de conclusion à leur
enterrement au tout début on est en page
page 7
non papa le souhaite puisque p771
biographie alors je vais retrouver là la
citation
voilà tu écris tu écris que tu as
consacré ta vie donc oui pardon c'est
bien ou pas cette cédant tableaux
graphiques tu crées que tu as consacré
ta vie je cite al aqsa voir les ma
question elle est très simple pourquoi
consacrer sa vie à la compréhension du
monde et à la transmission du savoir
parce que c'est inscrit génétiquement en
nous les hommes
l'homme ne vivent en fin de compte que
par son intégration au groupe et le
groupe en fin de compte ne survit que
par la transmission enfin compte du
savoir puisque l'homme est un animal
social est un animal qui transmet de
l'information et cette information
permet au groupe de survivre donc moi il
faut vivre mais je suis programmé pour
transmettre de l'information pour que
mon groupe soit plus résistant et pour
que la vie puisse continuer l'homme
puisse continuer à s'épanouir et
accueillir la conscience du monde ou de
dieu en ça je fais une oeuvre divine
c'est à dire que je transmet le savoir
dans mon groupe et dans l'humanité pour
que cette humanité soient plus
résistantes et pour que les hommes
puissent y épanouir en fin de compte
pour que dieu puisse continuer à y vivre
la relation à l'autre
aimer et être aimés en fin de compte
pour que moi en tant qu êtres divins
conscient de ça puisse continuer à vivre
près des rythmes heures mais dieu en moi
continuera éternellement on va dire
c'est plus longtemps possible à vivre la
relation à l'autre à aimer et être aimé
nous sommes programmés pour ça le savoir
permet à l'humanité en fin de compte de
survivre avant le savoir était imprimé
dans les travaux ça la culture n'est pas
n'existait pas réellement le savoir ça
promet dans des gènes puisque ce que
nous vivions notre confrontation au
monde
modifié à notre structure génétique et
ou réactiver certains anciens et jeunes
qui existe qui est vie était utile et
nous transmettions un pas dire un
patrimoine génétique modifié les foyers
des sélection aléatoire aussi qui
permettait enfin nombre de l'information
mais de l'information imprimée dans la
matière dans la matière vivante
c'était maintenant on peut en plus
transmettre de l'information imprimée
dans de la matière morte un ordinateur
qui viendra serez imprimé dans la
matière vivante augmentant la puissance
justement et l'information que les êtres
vivants pourront avoir pour maîtriser ce
bon y vivre et transmettre même vous
l'aurez compris un livre plein de
sagesse donc acheté le mais surtout
lisez le méditer le et transmettez à la
et l'essentiel c'est de vivre surtout un
gars qui veut qu'ils pensent avoir la
sagesse en s'isolant c'est souvent un
trou du cul parce qu'avant de mourir
s'apercevra qu'il est parti à côté de
l'essentiel c'est à dire vivre et vivre
vive la relation à l'autre aimer et être
aimé manger vous fait baiser aimé soleil
d'été et mais le vent froid de l'hiver
et mais le ciel étoilé et met la lumière
et mais l'obscurité mais le monde voilà
et vivre vivant voilà merci c'est la
base salut a tous c'était frais de la
vie''
[Musique]
les sexes mais aussi entre les individus
chacun ayant une place qui lui est
propre on va couper voie lactée pas
suivi ces mamans j'ai une vieille maman